تتجه الانظار الى اوكرانيا رغم الصراع
المحتدم في الشرق الاوسط المحادثات التي
جرت نهايه هذا الاسبوع في مالطه تعد
انتصارا لفلاديمير زيلنسكي خطته للسلام
حازت على تاييد بالاجماع وكانت مقنعه ايضا
لكل من الهند وتركيا
والبرازيل اقترحت العام الماضي صيغه سلام
عشر نقاط تغطي جميع جوانب العدوان الروسي
على اوكرانيا وتستند الى مبادئ ميثاق
الامم المتحده وقرارات الجمعيه العامه
التي وافق عليها العالم اجمع وخلال العام
اصبحت صيغه السلام الخاصه بنا عالميه
تدريجيا خطه من عشر نقاط تشمل بشكل خاص
الامن النووي والطاقه والغذاء وكذلك اطلاق
سراح السجناء وعوده السلام لاوكرانيا
روسيا التي كانت غائبه عن هذا الاجتماع
نددت قبل بدء القمه بما وصفته بالحدث
المناهض بشكل علني
لها المناقشات حول الخطوط العريضه للتسويه
السلميه دون مشاركه روسيا لن يكون لها اي
قيمه يستخدم منظمو الحدث كافه الوسائل بما
في ذلك الاحتيال والابتزاز والتهديد لجذب
اكبر عدد ممكن من الدول خاصه تلك التي
اتخذت موقفا محايدا بشان الازمه
الاوكرانيه وتاتي قمه مالطا في وقت تواجه
فيه كياف صعوبه على الارض وهجوما مضادا
يبدو مت ثرا لذا يخشى فلودمير زيلنسكي من
ملل وعدم اهتمام حلفائه
الغربيين